si on sait que karine le marchand a
longtemps été en couple avec un
footballeur aujourd'hui ses relations
avec les stars du ballon rond ne semble
plus aussi idyllique que dans le passé
du moins c'est ce qu'on peut constater
suite à une confrontation numérique
entre franck ribéry et l'animatrice de
l'amour est dans le pré karine
lemarchand fidèles sociétaire des
grosses têtes n'est jamais avare d'une
petite plaisanterie sur les réseaux
sociaux cette fois ci c'est un
photomontage sur franck ribéry que
l'animatrice a décidé de reporter pour
détendre ses followers mais visiblement
franck ribéry n'a pas beaucoup apprécié
la plaisanterie l'international de
football a même décidé de contacter son
avocat pour menacer l'animatrice de m6
de poursuites
agacé par les plaisanteries sur lui
depuis des années il vit aujourd'hui
préserver ses enfants selon son avocat
traiter de tels propos à monsieur franck
ribéry qui n'a demi cible en ce qu'ils
tendent à le rabaisser et à inciter les
utilisateurs du réseau social à se
montrer mais prison à son endroit
pourtant son avocat n'est pas favorable
à une action en justice en ce moment
pour lui une autre issue est possible
d'autant que la période nécessite selon
lui de la bienveillance et de la
solidarité entre les individus plutôt
que de la judiciarisation de conflit sur
fond de médiatisation de son côté karine
le marchand ne sait pour l'heure pas
excusé mais aujourd'hui ces tweets
semble protégé et inaccessible à ceux
qui ne sont pas abonnés à son compte une
réponse à ribéry
alors donc karine le marchand qui
s'était moqué de contre l'égérie sur les
réseaux le 16 avril dernier elle avait
publié une photo du footballeur suivi de
messages pour le sauveur de la nation du
pays reste on confites
voilà donc elle se moque de lui c'est
vrai qu'elle arrête pas de se moquer de
franck ribéry karine le marchand et je
vous le dis elle a twitté il ya pas
longtemps elle vient de dire sur un
stade qu'elle était au courant que
ribéry n'aimait pas qu'elle se moque de
lui qu'il souffrait qu'on se moque de
lui mais ça la faisait rire quand même
et elle trouve normal qu ils subissent
ça jusqu'à la fin de sa vie chez même
pas qu'il y avait une embrouille entre
franck ribéry karine et karine le
marchand
qu'est ce que vous en pensez sans
victoire ce que vous l'avez la manquer
mais c'est d'arles c'est dingue parce
que karine le marchand elle a été
victime de propos racistes je comprends
pas comment être quelques réagir comme
ça c'est vrai que franck ribéry il est
il a été victime de moqueries à
répétition esta sur son physique sur sa
dentition je te répète si blanc sur son
élocution je trouve ça monstrueux qu'on
puisse se moquer du physique de
quelqu'un et la manière dont il
s'exprime
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on se
moque en fait des petites gens c'est nul
et tiennent ils pensent eux jean michel
bats je comprends même pas au par foyers
détruits sont méchant ils sont drôles
mais là qu'est ce qui est drôle dans
pour le bourreau le bien-être reste on
confie ça veut dire quoi ça donc je
trouve que ribéry la gauche chose que
j'ai trouvé très touchant chez lui c'est
qu'il gagne pas d'argent mais il est
très doué évidemment et qui l'a jamais
ouvrir le plaçant si il est comme ça et
fils 10h et logistique c'est pas pour
moi j'aime bien entre un accident bien
sûr bien sûr
non mais mais il est pas dans ce truc là
lui les lois naturelles
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime bien citons
voter naturel je veux dire vraiment
question porte de cette histoire entre
karine de marquion et franck ribéry je
voudrais demander soit votre avis estime
karine lemarchand team ribéry je suis
pas du tout comment vois tu cette
brouille est valable artistes alors moi
j'étais pas au courant et je vais vous
dire franchement je tombe des nues et je
me demande si ce n'est pas une secte
news que les rats jaunes en dix ans il
va le payer toute sa vie là je marche la
jeune maman je comprends pas et surtout
skate comme à 10 aussi elle qui est plus
qu elle qui a été victime et qui est
peut-être cycle ex'im plus tard blog de
hors de propos racines esquissait que
l'intégrité de la personne à quel point
ça peut faire mal
elle a dansé dans le passé ou si elle a
eu des compagnes on a eu des compagnons
qui concourront eu atteinte à son
intégrité physique à elle elle est tout
le temps parfois en train
landes là j'espère qu'elle va s'excuser
très vite parce que comme a dit
jean-michel ribéry y fait la fête le
quart de ce que fait ribéry me donne à
des associations à gauche fait le quart
de gagner le cargo de l'asie fait me
tarde de la venue de ribéry
et après vous viendrait donner des
conseils mais de montrer sa tête pour
serge en 8c la caisse c'est le
confinement c'est ce qui vous arrive
estime sortez vous allait ressembler à
ribéry elle est complètement match 70e
je m'en fou qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à
l'ats elle met le confirme éric berry et
victor lanoux prépa quand on va à la
critique et karine lemarchand je te le
dis je t'aime bien celle de l'amour est
dans le pré c'est marrant ton émission
excuse que tu as chaud là et ça envoie
un mauvais message qu'il n'y aura pas de
pain pas de critiques nées poste pour
fusil j'espère que tu terrab le jour
entre critique toi sur ta tête
il faudra lutter c'est un conseil que je
donne et si tu spa carita berné de
meadow a à z à la mairie ça à
l'interdire il relate le physique n'est
malheureusement lui connaît vous connais
même pas il a toujours été victime d'un
délit de faciès à l'argent il faut pas
enlever d'oise ont [ __ ] bon et que tu
cautionnes est-ce que tu connais qui ne
veut pas cautionner et cyrille comar qui
veut que la wii je cautionnerais une
telle chose alors que nous on parlait de
la chanteuse appréciant la qui était
venue de l avis de bois est évident mais
non oui je connais moi j'ai horreur déjà
justement que du physique et des genres
en deçà voilà on peut se marier on peut
se marier pic mais on peut pas dire à
quelqu'un tu es moche on peut pas dire à
quelqu'un et puis dont elles se moquent
surtout de son voeu de dieu du fait
qu'ils soient bête elle dit qu'il est
bête mara ces sales histoires aussi ses
sacs mais elle est intelligente elle
elle est intelligente elle excite c'est
québec qui c'est qui est intelligent on
est toujours le con de quelqu'un quand
tu commences à te dire mais les bêtes
noires
moi je suis un idiot je ne sais j'ai
arrêté l'école à 15 ans moi je suis bête
ça veut rien dire
plus intelligent quelqu'un de doux nous
on dit il va vivre avec ça toute sa vie
tour 10 je préfère la tête par les je
vais te dire des conneries non mais
n'hésite pas à dire des conneries il a
l'habitude dans l'édition intérêts
privés non de dire oui après jeu après
je vais avoir l'avis de mathieu parce
qu'elle s'était déjà pris c'en était
déjà pris à mathieu également et à kelly
1 dans l'émission donc et c'est vrai que
ça je sais que ça vous a des penne
mathieu de passe
jean michel est là où rémois raison
c'est que faire ce genre de déclaration
de postes c'est vraiment pas une preuve
d'intelligence c'est vraiment pour le
coup une preuve de conneries donc
l'arrêt mange donne raison
c'est vraiment il devrait mettre fin aux
aguets pour sa déclaration comme ça
aussi conne castaldi d'un geste on a vu
des jordils côté suspendu pour des
propos voilà très très mal à doha nous
on a pris des amendes parce que voilà et
elle a le 10 mai et personne derrière on
ne suspend pas il ya la chaîne ne réagit
pas je suis désolé deux poids deux
mesures une fois de plus on aurait fait
la même blague nous on arrive la même
chose de terrain ou assassinés comme
toujours on est lancé comme ça mais tu
pas d'accord moi franchement ou m6 alors
de karine le marchand
le fait sur twitter on verrait au
benjamin benjamin m6 est passé par an il
fait ce qu'elle veut elle a dit sur les
réseaux secs de s'excuser
l'adie sur les réseaux c'est sa vie
privée m6 à la limite ils sont ce qu'ils
valent
mais sauf que quand on va là crétier
qu'est faudra pas qu'elles viennent
pleurer il faut pas que l'âge la peau
vous me dites qu'à l'impact de leurs
mots et kelly faut pas attaquer les gens
parce que si et quand on va t'attaquer
poids c'est la première à venir pleurer
la première à 0 mds
on m'a dit ça ça m'a touchée ça m'a
peiné faut pas alors ça ça
scala fait c'est pas bon mathieu mathieu
delormeau mathieu ben bardon mais j'ai
l'impression que vous débarquez un petit
peu tous et j'étais quand même l'un des
premiers à le dire on y pense vraiment
que karine le marchand est une fille
gentille je pense que karine lemarchand
d'abord méprise totalement la plupart
les agriculteurs lorsqu'il y va avec ses
talons et quelques les fausses
d'interviews gentille je pense qu'elle
n'a pas une once d'empathie
l empathie pour la chaîne mais pas du
tout pour l'émission et pour le reste
c'est pas la première fois qu'elle est
dans des clichés elle a effectivement
tacler kelly parce qu'elle est ainsi à
fait qu'elle est blonde elle m'a taclé
mois dans une émission parce qu'elle m'a
traitée de sombre idiot
là elle tacle de ribéry et même que
ribéry une bête caillou enfants fou
attaques de ribéry parce que c'est un
fou de bonheur voilà il se trouve que
karine marchand depuis le début mais
pardon renseignez vous un petit postier
c'est important sur les gens souvent qui
sont derrière les caméras derrière les
équipes voilà karine lemarchand oleme on
n'aime pas prenez pagne qui très
sympathique et c'est une fille je trouve
qui a tendance à mépriser beaucoup de
monde et le dire de plus en plus parce
qu'elle a un petit l'amène de surpoids
parce qu'elle finition qui fait digne en
téléspectateurs non matenda ou non ils
sont libres ils ont pas aux ennemis
maladroit effectivement effectivement il
se permet un petit peu tout elle méprise
totalement les gens j'étais l'un des
premiers à dire et de trouver que même
également ses interviews de 2,2
d'agriculteurs été fait dans le mépris
de ce petit côté parisien en rigolant
voilà moi comment karine lemarchand
maintenant c'est uniquement à m sila qui
me fait rire quand le rire les méprisent
leur va très bien et ben écoute voilà
qu'un iran n'a pas entendu valérie
bénaïm mathieu oui vous avez raison
syrie quand vous visiez on a le droit de
charrier bien sûr qu'on a le droit de
chercher et il a l'art post est en fait
une story de quelqu'un d'autre
c'est à l'origine du truc mais quand tu
sais quand tu te rends compte que ce que
tu as fait que ce que tu avais posté à
blé laissé la moindre chance faire
marche arrière et de venir écouter sur
le site sept pôles en fait c'était pas
le rocher à côté de la plaque mais je
l'étais fait de la banshee pardon voilà
c'est aussi simple que ça parfois il
faut simplement reconnaître s'est trompé
c'est tout à fait ce qu'il dit et moi
jamais et sait jamais ce qu'il est il à
mathieu c'est vrai qu elle a laissé et
elle a laissé son poste sur un statut
peut rappeler ce qu'elle avait dit sur
kelly et toi ma que quand la bêtise chez
paco âge à la victime hanche depuis
parker malheureusement mais
effectivement accru de cantley
quand là quand la bêtise et et je sais
plus quoi et et le vide s'additionnent
s'adonne kelly et mathieu dans tpm fait
un truc comme ça allait vraiment
dangereux des magrets annonce excusé et
elle avait dit qu'elle ne s'excuserait
jamais de surcroît sur aucun testament
n'est même pas drôle c'est fait pour
faire mal et bon bah voilà mèche plutôt
content parce qu'on est en train de
boire le vrai visage
le vernis craque et c'est vrai que sa
cote et tombe voilà un petit peu mais
elle reste quand même une bonne
animatrice voilà après contre elle fait
de moins en moins de choses sur m6 à
part l'amour est dans le pré c'est vrai
qu'elle fait pas grand chose sur m6 mais
ignorait aussi raymond barre juste un
bémol c'est vrai c'est blessant je peux
comprendre que ce soit blessant ce
qu'elle a fait avec matthieu delormeau
et avec kelly je peux comprendre que ce
soit très blessants juste seul bémol que
jma c'est qu'elle a réagi peut-être à ce
qu'on avait dit sur un plateau de télé
peut-être sur une émission sur des
propos qu'on avait eue sur elle ça c'est
vrai j'ai rien à dire
mottaki avait rien de grave mais c'est
peut-être léger et elle a sur réagi en
revanche sur ribéry libérer la jeune on
n'a rien à perdre et karine lemarchand
libérer l'algérie la bolivie c'est le
marchand ils sont aptes au talent mais
vraiment pas bon c'est mal et qu'elle
existe bah oui je crois que c'est même
pas qu'elles exigent michel mr oui non
et valérie j
quand tu mets des propos comme ça que je
progresse à blaye snoop excuses il n'y a
même pas besoin d'avoir fait sciences po
vous savoir avant le publier que quand
tu va publier ça ça m'a blessé c'est
simple comme des propos ils sont c'est
que pour blesser faut quand même pas
vous aurait touché après faut pas le
cers